what first your reaction to the breaking  news that I've been able to confirm that  the Attorney General has not recused  himself from the uranium 1 investigation  well it's very interesting if you go  back and look at the transcript of  sessions confirmation hearing three  times he promises to recuse himself from  anything related to Hillary Clinton that  suggests to me that the Department of  Justice is looking very closely at all  of the aspects of that crooked uranium  one deal it was corrupt it was  racketeering bribery extortion kickbacks  and so on they're looking at that and  who covered it up by not telling  Congress about it which would have  certainly killed the deal well we know  that Robert Muller rod Rosen Stein and  Andrew Weissman were involved in the  uranium one deal and knowing about the  illegality of it and didn't tell  Congress and those three men are now  presiding over the Trump Russia case